E aí
[Música]
e tudo começou quando eu era criança
sempre uma criança peralta minha mãe
sempre falando meu Deus do céu como que
você é um artista né porque eu vivia com
muita peraltices pintando a casa da
minha vó minha vó artista também
riscando tudo eu sempre scatia caminhou
podia ver uma caneta um lápis e um dia
eu estava pintando lá minha mãe chegou e
falou assim meu filho para de fazer isso
isso não dá futuro eu olhei para minha
mãe e eu tinha 89 anos foi um dia que eu
fiquei muito triste mas também minha mãe
não tinham conhecimento artístico ela
não entende de arte como eu também não
eu gostava mas não entendia fui para
fora da casa sentei olhei o muro tinha
uma sombra e eu vou fazer um relógio e
comecei colocar horas
A Sombra e hoje eu entendo que foi o meu
a minha primeira experiência meu
primeiro relógio solar e nisso com 14 15
anos eu tive uma experiência de entrar
no primeiro acumular uma cidade natal e
eu tive um mentor e eu ia toda tarde
para casa dele e ficava Maravilhado com
aquele Universo de tinta de pincel de
escultura de Yuri cara que legal eu
quero isso eu quero ir para minha vida e
só isso mas assim eu não entendi muito
bem e ele sempre eu falo que ele é o meu
primeiro mentor e eu sempre escutei ele
como é importante nós temos uma em torno
a vida né e o dia de tantas conversas
uma conversa que me chamou muita atenção
até hoje que eu tatuei no meu coração e
coloquei na minha mente ele falou o
seguinte Chico meu apelido era Chico na
época né Chico eu
a unidade de consumir a tecnologia mas
eu fiquei na zona de conforto e eu sem
entender como assim tá consumir
tecnologia zona de conforto explica
melhor então tá eu trabalhava na época
não existia computadores como hoje eu
pintava para marcas para agências fazia
Outdoor fazia adesivo camisetas lonas
tudo de publicidade e as pessoas me
ligavam Tinha agenda gigante a minha
agenda eu era muito próspero
e quando veio o primeiro computador para
Cuiabá e começou vir e oferecerão cursos
de arte digitais de entrar nesse mundo
tecnológico sabe o que ele fez Não isso
aí não vai virar isso aí não tá parece
que isso aí vai substituir a minha
criatividade isso são palavras dele não
me está E aí e eu sou vindo e aí o que
aconteceu ele então juner depois de dois
anos eu tive que voltar para Cáceres
porque a tecnologia me consumiu e até
hoje é uma dificuldade de entrar nesse
mundo tecnológico e é muito triste vim
para Cuiabá com esse pensamento falei
cara eu preciso ser um profissional
tecnológico eu preciso consumir a
tecnologia como que eu vou fazer isso E
aí eu comecei a fazer curso de Photoshop
3D tudo que era possível consumir a
tecnologia entender com funcionário
tecnologia só que um
o preconceito muito grande mas será que
eu vou deixar de ser tímida por causa da
tecnologia Porque até então ter artista
para mim era o pincel e uma tela e
grampo tintas e eu saísse dessa desse
momento Templo de pintura de tela eu ia
deixar de ser tipo eu ficava com muito
medo foi meu Deus agora como que eu vou
fazer isso só que eu falei não eu
preciso consumir a tecnologia e eu
lembrava dele do momento que ele passou
para mim não Agora que comecei O que que
está por vir o que que vai ver comecei
estudar o urso eu preparei com estudo de
Salvador Dalí Salvador Dalí é uma
referência muito grande nas minhas AIDS
e naquela época não existia computadores
mas ele tinha fotografia e o que você
fazia para ir estudar a luz sombra
fórmulas
e eu tirava foto ele jogava a goiaba
sair e jogava até animais assim ele era
muito doido nós jogava assim ele tirar
uma foto e ele estudava como que
funcionava o movimento da fotografia
então naquela época era a tecnologia de
ponta dele eu falei cara que viagem é
essa eu fui perdendo o medo eu falei vou
usar a tecnologia a favor da arte É isso
aí se comecei a iaee e nisso eu comecei
a pensar cara e Van Gogh se tivesse hoje
em vida porque caro Van Gogh né morreu
sem ninguém saber que ele era o blog
depois de tantos anos que ele fez fama
falei meu Deus imagina Van Gogh com a
tecnologia de hoje cara realidade
virtual imaginei fazendo céu estrelado
daquelas obras eu comecei a viajar
clicar em Salvador Dalí com a tecnologia
faz ferramenta
o Photoshop Illustrator para o cliente
iPad imagina o a loucura que ele ia
fazer as artes dele eu falei cara não
posso perder tempo eu preciso ser eu não
quero ser o melhor eu quero ser uma
referência para minha geração para
próxima geração porque a tecnologia ela
nunca vai substituir Nossa criatividade
mas ela tava muito emprego e precisamos
estar consumindo aí eu falei e Leonardo
E se ele Pintassilgo Monalisa com a
tecnologia imagina viagem Por que há
tantos códigos que ele colocava imagina
hoje em dia ele usando a tecnologia A
favor dele meu Deus do céu Leonardo ia
pirar e nisso eu comecei a entrar de
cabeça na tecnologia e vai e me
preparando de repente chega esse ano o
ano muito diferente eu tenho certeza que
nenhum dos nossos antepassados passaram
um ano igual esse ano que tivemos um ano
tão atípico chamado pandemia meu Deus e
a pandemia veio porque eu falo tudo tem
seu propósito pode ser o propósito
positivo ou negativo e a pandemia veio
com todos os propósitos e um deles a
tecnologia cresceu muito se você não era
uma pessoa tecnológica hoje
Bom dia daqui você é que você não era
uma pessoa criativa eu tenho certeza que
você se tornou uma pessoa criativa
Imagina ficar 30 dias dentro de casa sem
sair meu Deus porque se eu sair eu posso
pegar isso tantas notícias negativas e
você consumir aquilo que eu tenho
certeza que o mundo da arte aumentou foi
um dos períodos que mais eu e minha
esposa conseguimos ter um aumento de
vendas de obra de arte então a arte
serviu para salvar esse momento tão
marcante em nossas vidas então
conseguimos nos tornar pessoas criativas
tecnológicas tudo isso mas eu vou falar
para vocês precisamos tomar cuidado
também com a tecnologia porque tem seu
lado bom e seu lado ruim como tudo na
nossa vida
o e precisamos consumir a tecnologia tem
consumo consciente Porque Nós não
sabemos o que está por vir ou está por
vir coisas muito ruins Então precisamos
entender e ver o que que está por vir e
não tem como falar da criatividade sem
citada onde vem essa criatividade da
onde a minha fonte de criatividade de
todos os dias até interessante combina e
atividade a minha fonte é do criador de
Cristo EA sua da onde é a sua fonte
Muito obrigado
E aí
[Música]